some say that beauty is in the eye of
the beholder so behold
me today we're all going to make
heightened more perfect versions of
ourselves today we are all going to
become
handsome squidwards let's take a look
so we're getting really deep into unreal
engine because it's a very powerful tool
to make
virtual productions very quickly
normally we star in our live action
videos and so we want to represent
ourselves in these virtual production
videos as
well however we have one advantage here
since we're controlling
everything about what we look like we're
going
to perfect our form now we are facing
one bottleneck though it's easy to make
environments it's easy to have an
animated camera
but characters require a ton of work
there's texturing there's modeling
there's sculpting there's rigging all
sorts of these things that require
days not weeks per character i need each
step
in this process to be as streamlined
as possible now last week the made a
human project from unreal engine
they released a sneak peek for it it's
really really cool stuff however
it's not going to be out for maybe a few
more months if not longer maybe a year
it's it's cool but it's still not a
viable option for us
to actually generate characters so today
we're going to test out
a new path forward to create characters
there's a really cool application called
character creator three these guys have
been around for a long time
but recently they've taken some pretty
huge steps
and made everything way more realistic
so
we all need to get our hands a little
bit dirty because
we want to reach our most perfect form
and so today we're all going to make
these heightened more perfect versions
of ourselves and so for that
we turn to the most perfect form
handsome squidward you're even more
handsome now
this is this is the this is perfection
of the human form this is this is pure
beauty right here
squidward got hit in the face by
spongebob on accident
somehow his face got like nicer and more
chiseled so he's like he forced the
spongebob to bash his face in
with the door again but when he looks at
him he's even more handsome
the perfect specimen he's just the
perfect being he's
just amazing almost like an alien
creature never seen something so
beautiful
in my deepest darkest moments when
people when people look at me and just
like dude that guy's so ugly
you know it's like you know what i wish
i had something for the for that person
i wish i could just turn and be like you
know what
and they're just like oh oh my god this
is the most beautiful man i've ever seen
in my life
there is one film that has attempted to
make their
most handsome squidward actor and that
was prometheus
look at him look at how handsome he is
just look at his bone structure
hot yeah he's making me rethink some
things
i mean if i could just be milky white
with no hair
with enormous the highest cheekbones
you've ever seen
i i would sign up for that program in a
day what if i told you there was that
program
oh there is right now i just want to
walk you guys through like
here's the general order of operations
it's a really easy application to use
there's a button up here
that says morph if you click it it
allows you to select parts of the body
and
you know mess with it oh my god
so there's also like full body morphs as
well too
so we can turn them into a lady really
quickly but then we can also turn them
into
a more buffed and we can turn him into a
freaking
oh my god
[Music]
wait no i want to see that dude i want
to see a buff slacker
and then you want to go see the max buff
nest
[Music]
they have a matching buff head
the morphs are pretty sweet they're very
powerful they allow you to get really
fast results
we can apply the herculean texture
to this which starts to make it look a
little more realistic let's
oh my god but we can take that further
here
you can take a baby skin texture and put
them on the buff am i gonna do it baby
skin
on buff man
you're telling me we can motion capture
this guy with facial capture
in unreal and bring him to life in full
ray trace beauty yes like if we can
bring him to life they'll be walking
talking peter i'm gonna take a photo of
you
three two one jeez all right wait like
do you
put that photo into the program and it
generates your face based off the photo
it's not that bad actually it's
something like the video game version of
you that's still the same facial
structure
it's not perfect but it gets you pretty
close with like trying to make a
a person or recreate them what we're
gonna do we're just gonna like stand in
a circle and then we
pick the person on our right and we're
all going to take a photo of them
nice flat neutral photo and we will
attempt
to recreate the other person or make
them much better
we all got at least a sprinkle of body
dysmorphia so the only way we can really
get a true picture of our
truest perfect selves is if somebody
else does it i have clint
clint i hope i capture your likeness and
make it even better
sam as soon as i capture your likeness
i'm going to turn you into a neanderthal
and send a picture to sarah
i'm doing peter everyone says peter's
perfect but
i think there's room for improvement i
got freaking nico and
i'm gonna make him handsome
[Music]
there's a check box that says select if
subject is a baby
so i was like sam's a big baby
that's a big old man baby baby
that baby is rich
baby was using the umbilical cord as
like a tension cable
so i got digital peter it's all right
it's like it
i mean certainly it resembles him i
noticed he was actually sunburned
so i found sunburn layers that i just
put in there to just give him a little
bit extra like discoloration and
unevenness so i look at it it's like
it's close but like this is where it
just gets to
the whole like artistry element of like
how well can you recreate someone's face
how how do you pick up the details
i'm trying to match the profile right
now you know because it does
you feed it the front on image which
does pretty well but it doesn't have any
data of the side of the head so i'm
going in and manually tweaking the shape
of
nico's profile to match him i'm trying
to get a bit more realistic before we
dive into the crazy stuff
clint's ears are really high up most
people's ears here sam look at me
man he still follows the normal routine
most people's ears line up with the
bottom of their nose
i literally had the slider all the way
max and still not quite enough to get
his ear
that's heavily influenced by the prim
tech video
is that the baby from spirited away
that's really good
i'll tell you do you want to see peter
it's like
it's peter like he kind of looks like
gary oldman you're right
peter is a young gary oldman but instead
of getting into acting he got into
blender
all right so i got niko pretty close i
feel like nico looks great in a nice
pair of overalls
this is a weird conversation to be
having at work to push this to the next
level
what should we do what should we enlarge
stretch
shrink that's actually not bad like does
sam
[Music]
dude put some paint on that so he had
pants he had pants
there's a million sliders for me to go
through but as far as like all right
someone in the office will see this and
they'll go like oh that's peter i think
we've gotten that far
but that's really impressive it
resembles him yeah that's peter 100
his hair is too brown or whatever yeah
maybe i'll do a little more tweaking
and then i will perfect him he's getting
handsomer
every second all right i'm gonna make
him look exactly like handsome squidward
the key to handsome squidward his his
face is swollen
from hitting things puffy lips puffy
eyes puffy cheeks
excellent
[Laughter]
oh we're making nico beautiful
you look like joker you know big eyes
are attractive so i thought why not
impart nico with these beautiful big
bulbous eyes
you got it you got it dude
i need like oh
sam had some work done
this is just straight up a caricature of
clinton now you don't have to go too far
though there is i think a key element
here which is that bottom lip
and that top lip that's it that's it
right there
it's important that i be uh nuanced in
my approach oh my god
dude that's pretty good
see that pose look at them look at that
like that's what i want i want the the
grace
of a ballerina i need more abs
oh wait no no it's the skin it's all on
the
it skin did it
[Laughter]
i think that's it no i think it's
perfect
dude oh my goodness
oh my goodness it's freaking adrian
brody so hanson squidward is not just
a big buff dude he's like very clearly
skipped leg day
okay this is giving me inspiration for
mine i feel like i went way too crazy
off the bat and i need to
tweak a lot more things a lot slower as
opposed to just
going ham on a few select features
handsome peter
[Laughter]
look though look look look he's handsome
i see he's so handsome
[Music]
oh by the way he's also like four feet
tall
right now i think i got it dialed in i
don't think i'm going to push it any
further here
i'm ready for uh the big lights
i've reassessed and i've come back at it
with a new mindset
now i feel like i still have the essence
of nico in here but it's
more beautified and handsome squidward i
virtually rubbed niko down with baby oil
i think i got something great nico is
going to be
truly beautiful i mean niko's a good
looking guy but
i don't know if he's beautiful beautiful
not like handsome squidward
so this is sam in his final form i
thought giving him some
long flowing fabio style hair was
totally fitting
he kept the jeans because they were
sentimental for him and so are the boots
i think it really brings out
his abs alright so my perfect sam is
done
i'm gonna send it over to him and
hopefully peter's motion capture
performance can live up to the beauty
that this render exudes all right so
everyone made their models so today
is the special day where we bring
everything to life we're going to throw
a mocap suit on here we got some gloves
we even have a head mount which we can
use phones
to track our face we're going to capture
the likeness
of the man before and the likeness of
the new man after
i have a newfound respect for clint for
wearing this thing all day in the desert
because it is
so tight thankfully they give us modesty
shorts so you can get around the
curvatures
that you want to keep modest gotta get
nice and stretched dude
don't uh you know smash any acls on the
fields
oh baby
all right you look stupid i look like
freaking nigel from the thornberries
what characteristics does my beautiful
self have uh
big muscles a handsome face very shiny
very
very shiny all right peter get ready to
show off your new body
okay ready and action
[Music]
what oh what
oh no
happy dance happy dance where's that
music
everything crashed everything's just
crashed and we lost all our data
it never goes smoothly
unsaved project data sound yeah
nico needs to be tough guy you're like a
robot
[Music]
you are a perfect automaton
you're so jacked up on steroids that you
might break someone's neck
i wasn't feeling that one
[Music]
my inner spirit was being captured right
there oh this one's going to be you this
one's going to be me now
what do you feel like i feel naughty we
need to try naughty i can do naughty
let's do naughty
naughty make me proud peter
[Music]
you know i did feel very naughty when i
was doing that
what's called quits all right sounds
good you said you'd never work with me
again after avatar too
i appreciate you coming back for one
last stripper
job this was really fun i'd be happy to
do this anytime
all right so all we got to do now is i
need to go through everyone's files
export models of the characters the one
plus of using iclone right now is it
makes it so i can take this mocap data
and swap any body model in there even if
it's bigger or smaller
anything because it's magic making it
sound really easy
hopefully it is
so i built up this game environment
based on the krusty krab
i basically went through as i deleted
all the lighting and i rebuilt
all the lighting with ray trace lighting
and i built
a fancy stage truss system they have
this truss system these hollywood lights
so i hit play here you'll notice the
whole environment kicks into gear and
things start moving around
all right so everything's placed we got
all the animations finally in
a lot of lessons were learned again on
this project big lesson is
it's incredibly hard to get all the
motion capture software
to play nice together what that's like
five six systems basically all
running in tandem and you know it's all
great software when used individually
the moment you start piecing them
together when
one thing goes wrong and the whole thing
falls apart and it's slogged through it
we got it all working here it's
definitely better than avatar too
so this is still just the beginning of
our exploration into
virtual production for unreal engine and
this is all building towards
future ideas for corridor videos and
also a project called local xero that's
on
corridor digital.com it's already been
greenlit if you haven't checked out our
site yet
please do it's got everything you see on
youtube except there ad
free as well as other exclusives like
our vlog and a bunch of other cool
upcoming shows like our d d show
and functional filmmaking where we kind
of bring you guys through some really
cool conceptual
tutorials and teach you about what we do
here also as a member of
corridordigital.com we're giving
discounts on all merchandise as well so
it's a great deal
so all the camera angles are in aside
from all the technical improvements
we'll eventually make to this workflow
from a standpoint of creating handsome
squidwards out of ourselves i think we
definitely succeeded okay it's time to
watch it
i don't know if i'm gonna be able to
live in this form after seeing my
perfect self
the reason i never made it in hollywood
is because i don't got the looks but
now with unreal engine i do
so you guys are going to see a little
fashion show if you will
so i'm so ready i'm just ready to see
sam's imagine
hi you might remember me as handsome
squidward
now before us we have four young
gentlemen
with one common problem with those faces
there's no way they're gonna be able to
cut it in hollywood but we have a
solution
with a simple slamming of a door to
their face we can chisel away all the
unnecessary fat and bone and create the
most
handsome versions of themselves let's
take a look
[Music]
oh my god the bone structure
[Laughter]
but they're like skinny at the same time
[Music]
okay
um
amazon
that's my favorite
[Music]
that's amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
peter was my favorite by far
you're like looking at his face and the
door slams and then he's gone
and then you like look way down there he
is
it was honestly amazing i love the anger
i love the passion i remember when he
was doing that exact
mocap for mikko because i was just
making a bagel and then he comes out
flipping everyone off in the kitchen
something about niko's just gives them
like dead eyes it makes you look like a
titan or something like that it's just
so good
the poses you do are really spot on
actually like if you hit some really
good poses
like that
[Laughter]
you did a really good job on niko's face
yeah
oh yeah yeah i think it does it
definitely looks like
the actual characters when you see them
up close look really
really good it's just right now i think
the like the overall animation
needs to like kind of walk in a little
bit better for it to feel a little
smoother and organic
it's the most beautiful thing i've ever
seen in my entire life dude micro peter
is
oh my god i i could only wish to live up
to that man
my shoulders were very bulbous
which is a good thing and you chose up
an opera dance for me too
yeah that was fully sam's directing you
got to thank him for that that was good
yeah that was very good
you know two or three years from now
when it's time for a little touch-up on
this i'll just take this picture to the
doctor and be like make it happen
yeah i mean you'll see these in the next
quarter video as we act as ourselves
if you like this video please consider
subscribing to corridor crew
you